oh yeah we're walking out here with big
titties
[Music]
yo yo what's up my name is Danny Brown
I'm about to answer the internet if you
can make any two people fighting a no
rules cage match who would you choose uh
that's easy Ray Charles and Stevie
Wonder
who wouldn't want to see that man put
them in the cage and let them find each
other okay what two artists would you
want to see battle rap what two artists
would I want to see battle rap that
would be great I think I would want to
go somewhere like um
two words that what would be a good
battle too it could be wrong I want yeah
I want somebody I want to I want to see
a good battle too okay I'll say uh
Childish Gambino and Chance the Rapper
I would love to see that battle rap
yeah that's the homie if you can make
your girlfriend breast as large my girl
has some pretty huge boobs she does she
got like the super huge boobs so I think
I think I already won this one all right
but if if yours had to be as big as hers
oh that's what they saying if you can
make your girlfriend breast large you
want it but you have to be the same size
how big would you go oh yeah we walking
out here with big titties
I want some Honkers some Pamela Anderson
Honkers man Double D's we hitting Double
D's if you could be a part of part of
the crew from any TV show or movie what
crew would it be I would be a part of
Mash mash yeah I don't know why but
something seems like ever been a great
time
so you always the cast of mash if you
had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
Aliens who would it be Orange Juice
Jones
He sings that song I saw you and him
walking in the rain why do you think
you'd be good for the aliens because
that song is amazing and I think we
could we could we can figure out
civilization like that is sex with
conjoined twins a threesome yeah it's
two people right I don't know is it I
mean it's one person two heads what if
it's one uh one vagina or one dick
it's still a threesome man you got to
make it come on man still you want to be
cool so it's the three you got to give
me my props man these are a 2.5 what are
the three greatest scrap albums of all
time
um
I guess that's easy to be Illmatic I
just feel bad that I'm just say all New
York albums and I wanna
at least say one West Coast album or
something else but no I got it okay man
it's Nas Illmatic Wu-Tang into the 36
Chambers and MOB deep hello Nerf who if
you had to pick a West Coast like what's
the three West Coast albums if I could
do that okay I'll do um any E40 album
you can pick any E40 I haven't put it in
there of course you're gonna have to say
The Chronic and uh
um I'm gonna just throw one out there
there's some that I really like that's
on my own terms and it would be rants
cast solo nice how many New York
[Laughter]
your first La album about seven
oh I forgot Spice One the very first
spice one album it's done so much for my
life if your arms were spaghetti well
you want them to be cooked or uncooked
they got like yeah I know I'm fearing
this situation up I feel like I want
them cooked because they'll be breaking
all the time if they wasn't you know
every time you bump it into something
wrapped around caress a girl face with
the noodle arms like what's up baby no
they are yeah she gonna be scratching
her you know what I'm saying at least
you got at least you saw yeah yeah I'm
already gonna slap them noodles on her
would you rather have free strippers for
life or a free pizza for Life man no
one's turning down a free pizza for life
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
and we got to eat in these streets would
you rather all your rap or your podcast
be completely PG rated
um PG rap is not going to be good at all
so I would say man you probably got more
of a chance of having a PG podcast I
know but you probably got real [ __ ] I'm
already [ __ ] up kind of so I feel like
I'm a PG version of me it's it's still a
little R-rated every time you got a
boner the song the same song would start
playing what song would you want oh man
that's such a good one corn Freak on a
Leash
[Laughter]
that's my boner Zone just the intro to
that alone sounds like a boner so what
you rather give hey the first 99 be the
last one percent of a blow job damn it's
a hard one I mean yeah
the 99 yeah I mean you gotta I'm gonna
go for the one percent man I'm not good
that's got to get it over with man that
[ __ ] that not that first 99 gonna be
dreadful for you man
would you bang your cousin to win the
hell yeah what is you talking about
Powerball
I think my cousin to be down with it we
gonna split talk this out
man yeah we banking cousins for
Powerball
if you go to a girlfriend house and meet
her father for the first time he hands
you an ox cord what song are you playing
first two Short Freaky Tales let them
know how I'm coming
Too Short Freaky Tales the last thing
you want to hear is a father [ __ ]
that's what I'm coming too I met this
[ __ ]
who is the most influential rapper of
all time ghost
figures people have done it before but I
just never seen a character like that in
hip-hop before he came the big fur coats
and old golden eagles and just give them
yeah and I could go Cameron too I can go
Cameron and dip set I'll go with that
cam had the the paint and all that yes
you know he was shutting [ __ ] down so
yeah ghost facing camera that's what I
say thank you man fun fun man
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out